[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport sur TV 78 l'émission ne
surtout pas manqué si vous êtes un
passionné de sport local aujourd'hui
comme toujours il y aura des analyses
techniques des décryptages et surtout
une dose de bonne humeur pour
m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau et ils sont en
pleine forme croyez moi présentation en
musique de cette dream team on commence
à ma droite musique c'est une légende
vivante un mythe c'est un guerrier une
lâche jamais rien dans l'arène du si on
parlait sport il est préparé il est
affûté à l'approche de l'été pour être
au top sur les plages tropéiennes notre
gladiateur Pierre Chevalier est avec
nous pendant une heure les plages du
sud-ouest de l'autre côté de l'autre
côté plutôt Pays Basque d'accord
à tous oui oui le printemps arrive la
saison de rugby va se terminer c'est la
saison de golf qui démarre donc oui oui
on a on a préparé les plaquettes de
chocolat
sans les manger juste là un petit peu
sur le fit voilà pleine forme Pierre
Chevalier Rubik club de Versailles on
continue à gauche musique vous
reconnaissez sa musique c'est là des
meilleurs journalistes sur le sport
italien et sur le sport et Benoît tel un
marché
chaque détail pour donner le meilleur de
lui-même dans cette émission de notre
italienne lover Grégory cannelés est
avec nous pendant une heure bonjour
Michael bonjour Pierre bonjour à tous ça
me touche que vous me comparez à
Marcello Lippi légende du football
italien qui a remporté la Coupe du monde
en tant que sélectionneur en 2006 face à
qui face à la France bien sûr
peaufiner tous les détails dans cette
émission tous les détails on se remet
tranquillement en selle ça faisait
longtemps que j'étais pas venu sur le
plateau avec la team on s'endort d'un
week-end pascal où il y a eu beaucoup de
chocolat ingérés donc il va falloir
faire du chocolat tablette de chocolat
voilà il va falloir éliminer tout ça on
passe de l'autre côté musique c'est un
petit nouveau mais il devient de plus en
plus grand il forge sa légende à chaque
émission et le Nord déjà
la sixième sélection dans ce si on
parlait sport il est responsable
sponsoring chez Orange en Île-de-France
il adore le sport il est amoureux de
sport mesdames et messieurs Philippe
volak est avec nous pendant une heure à
tous au plateau à toutes qui nous
regardent et je voulais faire un petit
clin d'œil aujourd'hui particulier c'est
les 80 ans de mon papa qui est
aujourd'hui qui est fan en plus de de
sport et donc voilà donc je voulais
tiens profiter de cette émission bon
anniversaire à lui j'espère qu'il est
fans de cette émission aussi il est fier
de vous on passe de l'autre côté musique
c'est la star mondiale que tout le monde
s'arrache il est iconiques pragmatique
photo génique féerique parfois coach
Jean Miss ex entraîneur du plaisir big
club est avec nous pendant une heure
coach comment allez bonjour à tous
pragmatique photo génique
iconique
pourquoi pas alors
on va parler basket et de notre
pépitvilloise Victor webanyama lors du
choc au sommet de la 27e journée de
Betclic élite entre Monaco et Boulogne
Levallois Victor et nouvelle fois
gratifiée les spectateurs d'un panier
complètement fou on regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous l'avez vu il recule tira 3 points
rate mais récupère le ballon pour dunker
un panier incroyable pour un joueur de 2
mètres 21 je le rappelle alors votre vie
tout simplement sur ce panier autour de
la table le premier c'est pas fait
exprès Michael vous pensez qu'il a fait
exprès de se le remettre à lui-même en
tout cas non magnifique et Pierre
commentait même l'action avant où il
emmène le joueur à droite à gauche il
fait ce qu'il veut avec le ballon il a
tout de suite vu que son panier à trois
points terre raté il est tout de suite
là à la retombé pour pour dunker j'avais
l'impression d'être dans dans Chucker
NBA le jeu vidéo parce que franchement
c'était assez beau c'était magnifique
genre c'est sûrement de quoi vous parlez
le jeu vidéo bien sûr
il est là alors qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez c'est remarquable
techniquement ils viennent de le dire
c'est vrai qu'il amène à droite c'est
pas spécialement mais c'est par rapport
à son gabarit surtout
c'est son gabarit qui fait que la
l'agilité qui peut avoir et puis le
[Musique]
de la saison prochaine il y en a eu il y
en a eu comme ça mais qui était pas
aussi complet dans le dans leur jeu je
pense à Manu de bol qui était Manu de
bol qui a joué dans les années 90 en NBA
Xiaomi le le chinois le chinois oui pas
la marque de téléphone ok
les Chinois qui était qui était qui
était impressionnant et qui était qui
était bon mais par exemple pas la longue
distance légèrement plus grand si mes
souvenirs
que Victor mais qu'il soit capable en
gros sur et puis en plus il fait il nous
fait un Rainbow shot à trois points il
va chercher derrière idunk il a il a
amené les défenseurs il s'est amusé
aussi avec avec chacun d'eux donc ce
gamin c'est de Laurent bar et s'il
continue sa progression comme ça
physique notamment en NBA il va tout
péter et c'est face à Monaco aussi qui
est une bonne équipe euh de la Ligue moi
je suis complètement d'accord
ils ont perdu 87 à 68 sur ce match
de cette phase ils étaient presque
devant ils étaient 62 quelque chose
comme non moi comme bon comme des
pierres c'est surtout c'est pas le avant
le les passe-passe c'est surtout le le
dingue enfin aller chercher le rebond de
son rebond lui-même et après le dunk
enfin je dis c'est d'aller le chercher
on le voit qui domine la raquette et
puis le panier et puis boum je veux dire
c'est c'est vraiment impressionnant
au ralenti mais pour avoir vu l'action
en temps réel vitesse normale
et ce cette image là on les a pris sur
le compte Twitter de la NBA donc la NBA
est quand même le scrute regarde tout le
monde se frottait déjà les mains est-ce
que ça l'aide à peut-être à grandir déjà
dans cet univers là de voir qu'à ce lien
avec la NBA déjà qui est en train de se
créer des millions en lumière il est
surveillé dès qu'il fait le petit
exploit tout de suite il est mis sur le
devant de la scène il y a une Statte
intéressante que j'ai relevé il est dans
le top 10 les joueurs les plus suivis
sur les sans doute réseaux sociaux de la
NBA il est numéro 8 alors qu'il a jamais
mis les pieds encore en NBA il est
numéro 8 de ce classement des joueurs
les plus vus sur les réseaux sociaux de
la NBA 350 millions de vues pour Victor
webmanyama bon il est loin du numéro 1
qui est LeBron James avec 1,3 milliards
de vues mais ça montre déjà qu'il est
scruté il est attendu par par les
Américains il va il va faire il va faire
une grande sensation en billet
l'anecdote aussi c'est que j'ai vu c'est
que Blois Le Portel c'est de toute
l'équipe enfin de première de première
division et ils ont ils ont demandé s'il
pouvait vendre des sons si vous pouvez
vendre son maillot dans leur boutique
c'est c'est quand même tu vois c'est
déjà
l'aspect phénomène et il domine tout le
monde physiquement la tête et des
épaules et en plus il est déjà en train
de se mettre sur des sur des pistes
extrêmement prometteurs de jeux de jeux
et de sport Basket assez dingue et
effectivement la NBA ne s'y trompe pas
attends avec impatience la prochaine
draft et où il devrait faire là aussi
sensation juste deux fois une VIP de la
bête clique élite cette année là la
dernière c'était le mois dernier en mars
donc ça prouve aussi qu'il allait les
résultats sur le terrain et pour la
draft du coup ce sera dans quelques
semaines alors trois équipes sont bien
positionnées pour l'accueillir des trois
pistons son Antonio et les roquettes de
Houston ils ont 14 % de chance de
pouvoir avoir ce fameux premier tour il
y a ensuite les Charlotte Hornets et
Portland ce serait bien qu'il y a là
peut-être à son Antonio Jean pour
l'histoire avec Tony Parker peut-être
ça serait plus pour vous ouais pour moi
oui j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien
personnellement j'aimerais bien qu'il
faut qu'il prenne le même même parcours
que Tony Parker
comme ça plusieurs comparaison peut-être
un petit peu plus proche si comme par
exemple c'est pas du tout le même pas
lui-même secteur de jeu pour vous
Philippe castré le meilleur choix
à l'écran et ça sera beau symbole qui
qui succède à la Tony Parker
et au niveau des équipes oui il y a
aussi piston les pistons c'est plus pour
l'histoire
justement je pense pas que c'était je
pense pas que c'est encore de nos jours
les bad boys des années 90 autour de
Thomas notamment les MBI et autres qui
donnait du fil à retordre notamment aux
boules de l'époque mais
le jeu peut-être le San Antonio
correspondrait plus à Victor et puis
dans l'actualité française ça
permettrait peut-être de de
faire diversion par rapport à
l'actualité récente notamment de Rudy
Gobert qui s'est fait un petit peu
remarquer à la récemment
une petite baston interne bon après je
pense passager il s'en est excusé depuis
bon après voilà donc mais de toute façon
il a une voix tracée ce petit Wambi ce
petit wemby qui va nous faire bien bien
plaisir vu de France et je précise de
certaines équipes font exprès de perdre
en NBA pour avoir justement ce fameux
dernier ce premier choix le draft en
étant dans les dernières positions je le
rappelle donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a
14% de chance pour trois équipes et
après un petit un petit peu moins pour
les autres équipes qui sont mieux placés
alors leur exacte sera connu le 16 mai
prochain les sud de la draft loterie
donc ça arrive bientôt alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de la diagonale des Yvelines une
course de 100 km était au programme dans
le département nous parlerons aussi de
karting et du prodige Jimmy Elias mais
avant de parler de ces thèmes on va
parler football
[Musique]
alors on va parler football dans cette
thématique est du FC Versailles dans le
championnat de National les versaillers
n'y arrivent plus dans cette fin de
championnat quatrième match sans
victoire les hommes de cris sont
arrachés le match nul dans le temps
additionnel sur la pelouse du stade de
briochin grâce à Gustave acouston le
score un but partout classement les
joueurs de la cité royale ne sont plus
les favoris pour l'accession en Ligue 2
ils sont pour l'instant à la cinquième
place à quatre points du leader
Martigues la question sur cette
thématique la montée en Ligue 2 est-elle
inaccessible oui ou non
non
compromise n'est pas inaccessible alors
pierre vous étiez un peu entre les deux
entre les deux c'est le terminal qui est
par définition par définition peut-être
pas peut-être pas évident dans cette
question là mais
c'est surtout sur le sur en fait sur
l'histoire du FCV en National on a
suffisamment parlé l'an dernier de
l'épopée et des promesses du FCV là
c'est c'est plus le FCV promu en
National qui redevient promu et qui à
nouveau connaît une saison qui qui
semble qui semble au départ promise
promise au promu sur la dernière série
je crois sur les six derniers matchs
c'est trois nuls de défaites une
victoire là on est plus on est plus sur
un sur un rythme de prétendant à la
montée en Ligue 2 de surcroît qui est
quand même un sacré un sacré Gap et
c'est cette impression vous l'avez
rappelé que que Versailles n'y arrive
plus
on en parlera sans doute de savoir si
les querelles extra sportives ou les
problèmes extra-sportifs n'ont pas rongé
le groupe de l'intérieur mais là en tout
cas il y a plus les recettes qui
fonctionnaient qui fonctionnaient pour
le FCV en début et en milieu de saison
toujours c'est question aussi de match à
domicile qui ne sont pas vraiment des
matchs à domicile les les perspectives
de le rapprocher au stade j'envoie ils
n'ont pas à Versailles et donc bon c'est
quasiment spectateur
sans assistance donc il y a pas de il y
a pas de douzième homme voilà et c'est
là c'est simplement constaté avec avec
un petit peu de déception ou de
tristesse par rapport aux attentes qui
n'étaient pas prévues au début de saison
et qu'on a commencé à avoir au fur et à
mesure des victoires mais bon là là on
va dire pour rester positif que que le
promu et c'est maintenu et que
maintenant a priori il est il est loin
peut-être de la marche de la marge de la
montée c'est pas impossible et
mathématiquement ça vient de plus en
plus difficile genre qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez
je suis un petit peu comme Pierre voilà
cette montée alors moi non je n'y crois
plus c'est fini pour vous
j'ai pas fini parce que ce sportive on
peut pas dire que c'est fini moi ce sera
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit j'ai dit non
aussi parce que
inaccessible non on peut il y a toujours
une pourcentage de qui fait qu'ils
peuvent monter mais qui est faible mais
c'est pas trop au niveau des résultats
c'est la manière donc la manière là là
le on dirait que il y a le ressort un
petit peu cassé sportivement et là ça
gagne plus ça gagne plus et il y avait
cette spirale de victoire de début de
saison qui faisait que là on commençait
à rêver on commençait à rêver déjà la
montée de de monter on parlait alors que
on l'a dit souvent sur ce plateau mais
un club qui monte et qui est promu
généralement on la première le premier
objectif c'est se maintenir consolider
pour après préparer la marche
supplémentaire et la montée là de suite
on s'est on s'est vu à espérer de suite
la montée et puis envisager des belles
choses et devenir une grande équipe dans
la cour des grands là je crois que ben
il y a quelque chose qui s'est cassé le
ressort est un petit peu pété et il
faudra peut-être revenir sur des
objectifs normaux comme on l'a dit
Pierre tout justement c'est un club
promu on va faire une belle saison parce
que faut quand même pas non plus
du premier donc on peut pas dire on peut
pas dire c'est catastrophique au
contraire c'est une très belle saison
c'est une très belle saison et il faut
justement tirer les bénéfices et non pas
à dire ah ben non c'est foutu on montera
pas oui mais c'était un luxe imaginez si
Versailles se monte cette saison ce que
ça peut engendrer avec ne serait-ce que
l'histoire du stade ne serait-ce que ça
l'histoire du stade oui parce qu'on ne
sait pas si mon temps Ligue 2 si ils
pourront jouer dans leur stade
normalement
impossible ça serait libre donc on le
sait que déjà je pourrai pas jouer ça
serait peut-être dans ma chambre
justement pour pour l'équipe de moi j'y
crois pas du tout ça ce ce ce
s'expatrier comme ça c'est fini on perd
tous ces racines on perds
plus
ce serait revenir sur des un autre
projet en disant enfin notre projet
d'autres objectifs plutôt en disant la
saison est réussie puisqu'on est promu
on est on est on est en haut on montre
qu'on est qu'on peut compter sur nous et
qu'il faut il va falloir compter sur
nous pour la montée mais comme ça ça
nous laisse un petit peu le temps mais
de s'organiser de réfléchir
éventuellement peut-être de construire
un nouveau stade ou de trouver d'autres
solutions qui seraient à mon avis plus
pérenne que celle du mangue et de l'île
pour éventuellement monter voilà
Grégory qu'est-ce que vous en pensez la
question est-ce que la montée est
inaccessible non puisque ça a été
rappelé il y a seulement quatre points
qui séparent Versailles de la Ligue 2
parce que on parle de la première place
aussi le deuxième Concarneau qui a 49
points Versailles doit jouer contre le
leader encore le match retour et aussi
contre le Red Star qui est devant
Versailles actuellement donc il reste
encore des des gros échéances pour pour
les versets maintenant il va falloir
vite réagir sur l'ensemble d'une série
de quatre matchs sans victoire avec
trois une défaite la dernière victoire
elle remonte déjà un petit peu de
semaine voilà ça fait quelques semaines
que Versailles ne s'impose plus ça c'est
une équipe mal cassée c'était
une victoire assez assez à l'arraché
parce que il ne marque pas beaucoup de
but aussi cette saison oui justement
peut-être les buts sur Versailles
Versailles arrive à marquer deux buts
maximum la dernière fois c'était le 17
février dernier ils ont marqué que 35
buts depuis le début de la saison c'est
moins que le Red Star Dunkerque
Concarneau 47 buts ou encore Martigues
donc c'est c'est pas une équipe qui
marque énormément de but à chaque fois
c'est 1-0 2 1 il faut dire aussi que le
championnat national est assez serré
très serré au niveau au niveau du du
niveau tout simplement et que des
grosses des grosses pardon Express
excusez-moi l'expression des des grosses
golayada des grosses j'ai il y a un mot
que j'ai pas envie de dire le but il y
en a pas énormément dans le championnat
de National maintenant à savoir on va
voir peut-être qu'on voir dans les
prochaines semaines si effectivement
c'est peut-être la crise en interne qui
a joué quelque part dans les mauvais
résultats de Versailles on le saura dans
les prochaines semaines mais peut-être
qu'il y a une explication à force
d'avoir des problèmes en interne
forcément à un moment donné ça se
ressent sur le sportif même si on nous
dit officiellement on avait reçu un jour
de Versailles c'était j'ai oublié son
nom c'était et ça va me revenir bon là
reçu il nous a dit non pour l'instant
c'est un influe pas sur le groupe
forcément au bout d'un moment ça influe
sur le groupe et là peut-être que ça
nous donne aussi des arguments pour dire
que que c'est bien le cas Philippe voilà
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez pour moi
déjà c'est serré parce que il y a 6
équipes à descendre quand même c'est
donc il se battent quand même
pas descendre effectivement
et puis bon ils se sont Saint-Brieuc ils
se sont costard briochin et ils ont
marqué vraiment à dernière seconde hein
je veux dire mais moi je me dis ils ont
leur destin entre leurs pieds c'est
parce que le dire parce que bon le
dernier match je crois qu'ils vont à
Martigues le dernier match de la saison
effectivement bon ils ont deux derby
autrement ils ont le Red Star à domicile
et Atlético mais Atlético aussi ils sont
avant dernier je crois Atlético donc bon
ils ont leur descend tout est encore
possible il y a eu aussi Concarneau qui
a gagné deux points sur tapis vert
regagné deux points sur tapis vert qui
les a fait aussi être plus haut aussi
alors qu'il serait autrement avec eux
donc l'oreille tout est encore tout est
encore possible là il reçoit
Villefranche je crois le prochain match
donc Villefranche qui doit-on 11e donc
c'est ouais après voilà il faut qu'il
joue mieux quand même que que ce qu'ils
font l'entraîneur Chris c'est un petit
peu critiquaire en ce moment on a pu
voir sur les réseaux sociaux que il
était pas mal critiqué en Christ
il est critiqué peut-être aussi à cause
des arguments qu'on avait dit au moment
de sa nomination de que c'était pas
forcément un entraîneur avec énormément
de vécu derrière lui et pas forcément
avec des énormes résultats mais il nous
a fait mentir sur le début parce que bah
sur le début avec Versailles il avait
une une série je crois qu'il avait eu un
nul sur ces cinq premiers matchs et que
des que des victoires moi je sais pas si
c'est sur crise qu'il faut il faut
mettre la faute je pense que le bilan
sera fait à la fin de la saison à mon
avis la crise en interne doit jouer sur
sur
le truc ça me revienne
Thibault Jacques Chris ou vous êtes fan
ou pas autour de cette table c'est un
tout parce que je me dis il y a eu il y
a eu l'entraîneur il y a eu Arribart il
y a il y a eu crise de direction sportif
qui est parti il y a vraiment eu une
année et c'est comme ça c'est quand même
pas mal de Gaby aussi il faut pas
oublier je trouve quand même
une addition de de d'éléments
extra-sportifs qui ont dû finir par
peser quand même dans la vie du groupe
et notamment dans la vie des dirigeants
ce qui est aussi des rumeurs qui qui
traînent sur la capacité de financement
du sponsor principal à maintenir ses
engagements et à garder le club à ce
niveau là je crois que sport forcément
extra-sportivement il y a plus de choix
dans la date c'est les 7 journées qu'il
reste pour pouvoir espérer alors
inaccessible pas forcément puisque là on
l'a tous dit mathématiquement c'est
encore possible c'est juste à mon avis
dans les têtes dans les têtes et le
mental que c'est pas forcément pas
forcément la bonne série là pour ça
et Michel ancien responsable
communication et recrutement du club a
dit qu'il a équité justement le club
pour un projet plus sain donc même dans
les hautes sphères voilà de dire qu'on
quitte Versailles pour un projet plus
sain il a tout dit en deux phrases il a
il a mis au jour tous les problèmes qui
existent en interne à Versailles alors
prochain match pour les versaillers ce
sera le vendredi 14 avril à 19h30
contrôle le FCVB au stade Jean-Bouin à
Paris on va maintenant parler de course
à pied ce samedi 1er avril était
organisé la diag 78 un trail avec quatre
épreuves qui traversaient le département
des Yvelines au programme un 100 km un
30 km un vin et un 12 km avec arriver
unique à Rochefort-en-Yvelines pour le
100 km c'est lui que gentilal qu'il a
emporté en 7h44 minutes et 59 secondes
avec une moyenne de 12,9 km/h avec près
d'une demi-heure d'avance sur le second
on écoute la réaction du vainqueur au
micro de Mathilde Franco c'est forcément
dur enfin moi j'ai optimisé mon
potentiel ça c'est à dire j'ai été
chercher
relativement loin alors j'ai pas fait la
bêtise de partir trop vite donc j'ai pas
souffert
j'ai pas souffert
de façon excessive mais quand même quand
on arrive au 60e kilomètre
qu'il en reste 40 et on sait que ça va
être dur et effectivement c'est dur
vous aussi pierre vous souffrez à partir
du 60e kilomètre en général
65e le double mur il est là il est au 65
de ces de ces hommes et ces femmes qui
se qui se fentent qui se fasse 100 km
comme ça
modestement terminé un marathon mais bon
pour un coureur de mon gabarit c'était
mon Everest à moi dans c'est aussi la
grande mode la grande mode du sport du
sport pour tous et du sport facile
d'accès je parle pas je parle pas de la
course en elle-même mais de la course à
pied en général et puis c'est de plus en
plus d'événements qui qui sont organisés
des courses des courses de Renault qui
qui connaissent leurs influences les
plus folles comme par exemple le
Marathon de Paris là encore encore
récemment il y a une quinzaine de jours
et sur le trail c'est aussi cette notion
de dépassement de soi de préparation
minutieuse qui impacte vraiment le
quotidien des coureurs coureuses et de
leurs familles et puis d'aller au bout
comme ça alors ce coureur là il a l'air
de il a l'air d'être entraîné parce que
il vient de sa voix de valoir donc je
dois connaître assez connu dans le dans
le milieu plus il connaît mais pour
s'enquiller 100 km en 7 heures comme ça
c'est c'est juste phénoménal moi ils ont
ils ont toute mon admiration et et je
trouve génial d'avoir ces possibilités
là donner à toutes et tous de faire du
sport régulier que ce soit sur 5 km ou
sur son genre vous en pensez quoi vous
de la diag 78 100 km
le célèbre chaîne une petite année de
préparation vite fait
7h44 12 km/h de moyenne à peu près 59
secondes
qui fait ce genre de discipline et lui
me disait que de toute façon après il
rejoint un peu c'est pas une fois qu'on
a une fois qu'on a fait qu'on a franchi
des Caps comme 60 km après c'est une
gestion mais
on peut faire on peut quand on fait 60
on a fait ça c'est c'est quoi à dire
mais c'est bête à dire pardon mais mais
c'est vrai moi ça me semble un peu loin
quand même on l'a fait à une époque mais
en plusieurs fois en plusieurs fois
alors au total 890 cours ont participé à
cette nouvelle édition cette quatrième
édition de la diag 78 est près de 150
pour le sang km on écoute l'organisateur
traverser un département c'est pas banal
pourquoi elle s'appelle la diag parce
que on a fait une petite référence à la
Diagonale des Fous qui traverse la
Réunion alors c'est pas la Réunion il y
a pas le même dénivelé mais on voulait
montrer que les Yvelines avaient un beau
territoire de trail et avec des chemins
des villages qui peuvent nous accueillir
comme aujourd'hui à
Rochefort-en-Yvelines et donc voilà donc
ouais c'est c'est je pense que c'est une
édition qui a amené à durée j'espère en
tout cas
alors la question sur cette thématique
la course peut-elle se faire un nom dans
le monde des trails
cette direction scientifique peut se
faire un nom oui oui Philippe
100 km c'est la seule en Île-de-France
en plus c'est la l'écoterelle qui fait
80 km qui part de l'île de 50 ans pour
rejoindre le premier étage de la Tour
Eiffel 100 km mais il y a celle le 20 il
y a 4 et 4 ou 5 épreuves épreuve donc 50
km 20 km 12 km
sur le 100 km je crois que l'année
dernière en 2022 et il a mis une heure
de plus celui qui a gagné une heure de
plus 8h49 et là c'est
7h4039
et 59 secondes l'année dernière celui
qui a gagné c'était une heure 8h15 c'est
c'est quand même
enfin moi si je m'arrête déjeuner je
prends un peu plus de temps
oui qu'est-ce que vous en pensez à
Grégory vous de cette course est-ce que
cette course peut se faire un nom dans
le monde des trails alors il y a bien
sûr la diagonale
on va pas la comparer à la diagonale des
165 km 10000 mètres de dénivelé il y a
le trail du Mont-Blanc aussi une autre
course comme vous en avez parlé c'est
c'est les cauterelles alors les
cauterelles on est sur un format un peu
différent 80 km il y a ce symbole de la
Tour Eiffel ce qu'on termine les
cauterelles en montant le premier étage
de la Tour Eiffel mais c'est vous qui
m'en avait parlé d'ailleurs Michael il y
a des il y a de plus en plus de
participants des co-trails qui sont
intéressés par cette direction 78 qui
ont rejoint en tout cas qui ont fait la
diagonale sur les côtés pour aller sur
cette Dex 78 et puis après voilà on est
on va pas on est on est les premiers
défenseurs de ce département on est dans
un très très beau département qui est un
pied dans l'urbain un pied dans dans le
rural dans dans Le Forestier donc il y a
différents paysages possibles
différentes possibilités il y a du
dénivelé enfin voilà il y en a vraiment
pour tous les goûts je pense que pour
faire un parcours de ce genre de 100 km
on a vraiment un territoire propice donc
pourquoi pas
sur cette course c'est impressionnant
quand même 95%
donc c'est normal mais on voit quand
même le nombre de participants moi je
pense qu'il pourrait il pourrait se
faire vraiment un nom pour moi il y a
deux choses on voit d'abord premièrement
le nombre de participants je crois que
c'était autour de 150 il y a 890
km c'est 150 pour le pour le 100 km et
je crois que c'était moitié moins
l'édition d'avant donc la troisième
édition là on était à la quatrième vidéo
sur le nombre total on a peut-être
augmenter aussi sur le total on a
augmenté voilà donc c'est que c'est
important c'est l'important c'est pas
focaliser la diag 78 sur les 100 km
puisqu'il y a 4 4 épreuves différentes
sur cette compétition donc c'est le
attirer le plus de monde possible et en
faire pourquoi pas
dans le cadre de tout ce qui est trail
une date une date importante faut-il
bien qu'ils aient le choix dans la date
sur le calendrier parce que et il va y
avoir un problème au niveau du temps
parce que ça c'est le genre de
compétition on peut pas le faire
n'importe quand dans l'année et c'est
uniquement ça mais si ils ont tous les
paramètres réunis ça peut devenir ça
peut devenir quelque chose de
d'instaurer et qui perdure ils le font
toujours le premier avril 2 avril à peu
près toujours début avril
qui sont pas venues que c'était un
poisson moi par exemple
ça c'est une blague c'est une blague
l'autre argument pour la pour la durée
et l'installation de cette course
dans le calendrier national voir
international c'est la concentration de
coureurs en Île-de-France on a on a une
des plus grosses concentrations de
population dans le dans le dans la
région et et de plus en plus de
pratiquants de la course à pied avec en
plus
monument d'un théâtre naturel génial
comme le département des Yvelines on en
parle souvent pour le vélo mais voilà
pour la la course à pied ça se pose là
donc oui il y a plus il y a plusieurs
plusieurs bonnes fées qui se sont posées
penchés sur ce berceau de course la
direction 78 reviendra à l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition la
cinquième elle sera toujours début avril
Jean si vous voulez vous inscrire alors
on va maintenant passer à l'envoler de
Grégory le moment le plus important de
cette émission de quoi allez-vous nous
parler Grégory certains diront qu'il est
normand mais les origines ça ne s'oublie
pas et une bonne partie des premières
années de sa vie Jimmy Elias les a passé
ici sur le territoire de 50 ans en
Yvelines à Guyancourt plus précisément
c'est d'ailleurs en Île-de-France qu'il
a effectué ses premiers tours de piste
une fois que j'ai dit ça les amis
savez-vous qui est Jimmy Elias
c'est la pépite du sport automobile
français il a été le premier pilote de
l'histoire numéro 1 de l'international
karting ranking dans la catégorie reine
premier pilote de l'histoire tout
simplement car ce classement est une
nouveauté créé et mise en place par les
FIA depuis le début de l'année un tour
de force extraordinaire pour le jeune de
14 ans face à des adversaires
professionnels plus âgés certains ont
plus de 20 ans et donc plus expérimentés
et de quoi rêver pour les prochaines
années espérer une accession un jour
dans le championnat le championnat de
Formule 1 son histoire avec le sport
automobile n'aurait pu jamais exister on
la doit surtout au hasard nous sommes en
2015 et Jimmy Élias vient de fêter son
septième anniversaire il n'est pas
passionné plus que ça de sport
automobile c'est plutôt son frère
Jonathan qui on est fan mais chez les
Elias on est amis avec une autre famille
leur nom va vous parler forcément c'est
les hautes-con au lendemain de
l'anniversaire de Jimmy Esteban au col
du fait un cadeau qui va changer son
destin une séance derrière un simulateur
le jeune Guyancourtois est trop petit
bien sûr pour atteindre les pédales il
donne donc des premiers coups de volant
directement sur les genoux du pilote
normand qui s'apprête à remporter cette
saison là le championnat de GP3 Series
en l'une des anti-chambres de la Formule
1 le courant passe tout de suite et
Esteban Ocon des selles en Jimmy un coup
d’œil un coup d'oeil hors pair si bien
qu'il convenait ses parents et lui-même
de s'essayer aux cartes et quand on est
fait pour quelque chose ça se voit tout
de suite en moins d'un an Jimi Ellias
participe à la Ligue d'Île-de-France
intègre le championnat de National
karting series et cours sous les
couleurs d'un constructeur italien et
oui pour le championnat de France face à
lui des gamins plus chevronnés mais
qu'importe Jimmy remporte le titre et
devient à 7 ans le plus jeune pilote de
tous les temps à avoir gagné un
championnat at national mieux qu'un
certain Lewis Hamilton devenu champion
d'Angleterre à 9 ans chez on you Lewis
Hamilton il y a qui a mis avec un moins
bien fait que que Jimmy Élias Mickaël le
talent du Guyancourtois vous l'aviez
vous-même décelé ne vous avez pas
échappé à l'époque voici ce qu'il disait
sur ses objectifs dans votre émission le
7 8 sport c'était en 2017 j'ai mis
quelle est la prochaine étape pour toi
déjà être champion du monde dans le
quartier et après être en Formule 1
alors tu es fan je crois de Lewis
Hamilton et
la Formule 1 le rêve d'un gamin un
objectif
en tout cas il avait battu sur le record
Lewis Hamilton donc c'est c'est le rêve
d'un gamin la Formule 1 un objectif on
ne va pas se le cacher très difficile à
atteindre jimmelias s'applique en tout
cas à cocher toutes les cases pour y
arriver des titres des sons plus jeune
âge on a parlé du championnat de France
il y a aussi eu la Coupe de France puis
des Grands Prix dans les championnats
internationaux sous la bannière de Tony
Kart Michael Schumacher yarnot trully ou
encore Sébastian Vettel son passé par
les rangs de l'écurie italienne une
collaboration fructueuse cinq ans de
cette collaboration avec à la clé de
multiples pôles et des podiums depuis
2022 Jimmy Élias a rejoint à Ward Racing
une écurie suédoise pour courir en
hockey c'est la catégorie reine du
karting et comme je le disais tout à
l'heure les résultats sont vite arrivés
il a terminé dans le top 5 de ces quatre
premières courses ce qui lui a permis
d'être le numéro 1 mondial en mars le
jeune pilote attire la lumière sur lui
il va devoir confirmer et mettre de côté
la pression il y a beaucoup de choses
avec Julien et je voulais le remercier
pour tout le travail qui fait pour moi à
6 mois motion vous êtes d'accord avec
lui
quels sont les pistes à améliorer selon
vous comme il l'a dit et puis aussi la
gestion de l'événement qui va être de
plus en plus dure au fur et à mesure de
l'année parce qu'il va de plus en plus
dangereux mais oui il sait très bien sur
quoi il a travaillé et on va travailler
là-dessus toute l'année pour pour
essayer de déchiffer l'empion du monde à
la fin de l'année
c'est très gentil à vous tiens la route
vers la F1 est longue et semer
d'embûches le talon ne fait pas tout
beaucoup de paramètres rentrent en
compte le paramètre financier en premier
lieu et le facteur technique qui lui a
fait d'ailleurs défaut en mars quand un
problème encore inexpliqué l'éloigner
des premières places lors de la course à
Valence en Espagne 28e à l'arrivée alors
qu'il était parti en pôle position un
résultat qui l'a fait glisser désormais
au sixième rang mondial en catégorie ok
mais bon Jimi Elias aura l'occasion de
se refaire le championnat d'Europe fin
mai le Championnat du Monde en octobre
sur le circuit de flanch accord en
Italie avant une course exhibition en
fin d'année ce sera à Las Vegas tout
cela pour maximiser ses chances d'être
engagé la saison prochaine en formule 4
ce qui peut sembler être un petit pas de
plus dans sa carrière ce serait surtout
un bon géant pour Jimmy Elias afin de se
rapprocher inexorablement de la temps
rêvée Formule 1 Las Vegas sans s'a fait
rêver j'espère qu'on sera Grégory hein
pour pour le suivre alors la question
sur cette thématique Jimmy Élias est-il
bien parti pour intégrer la Formule 1
messieurs
vous êtes partagé Jean partager aussi
Philippe et vous y croyez vous pierre
alors on va faire un petit duel entre
Jean et Pierre genre vous commencez
j'aime bien
je suis partagé on a déjà abordé ce
sujet mais il y a quelques années quand
on avait déjà parlé de lui il a grandi
il a grandi il a grandi il continue et
c'est bien ça c'est bien il continue ce
qu'on avait pu prendre pour un petit un
peu de caprice mais me dit joujou au
départ commence à venir quand même plus
qu'un jour là on commence à parler de
lui pour la formule 4 qui est déjà
énorme le palier là passer du karting à
la formule 4 c'est énorme après je dis
pas ce sera peut-être le le futur grand
champion Formule 1 pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas mais il y a énormément de facteurs
qui rentrent en jeu dans ce domaine de
notre sport dans ce domaine sportif
parce que s'il y a vraiment des sports
où l'argent est primordial mais alors
plus que primordial c'est
c'est c'est le le la base s'il y a pas
d'argent il y a rien du tout il y a pas
d'espoir on peut être le meilleur
il pourra pas y arriver donc ça déjà
c'est la première chose et la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il y a énormément de
monde et normalement le monde à ce
niveau là et très très peu de place à
haut niveau donc l'entonnoir se referme
très vite et après plus ça va plus les
critères sont énormes et les les
obligations sont de plus en plus grandes
alors c'est pour ça que je suis un petit
peu mitigé parce que il a 14 ans 14 ans
c'est vrai que là c'était 2017 la
dernière fois il a 4 ans pour pour y
arriver parce que maintenant il faut
avoir 18 ans et avoir le permis de
conduire maintenant pour aller en
Formule 1
le conduire à 16 ans maintenant il va
peut-être faire un bon peut-être mais
c'est vrai que 4 ans c'est demain 4 ans
c'est demain donc on sera quand même
assez vite fixé moi je pense que déjà il
faut d'ores et déjà qu'il franchissent
le cap et qui rentre en formule 4 si il
rentre en formule 4
pourquoi pas honnêtement si Simon pas de
suite en formule 4 ça va être compliqué
et qu'est-ce que l'équipe fait les
résultats et bien sûr
son ascension continue son ascension au
niveau des résultats et au niveau de ses
performances sportives voilà c'est
uniquement ça qui me bloque un petit peu
pas mal encore une fois là mais vous
restez prudent voilà j'y crois je crois
toujours un sportif surtout que là
encore une fois c'est plus un caprice
c'est quand même c'est un champion c'est
déjà un champion à 14 ans Pierre
Chevalier moi c'est les deux arguments
au départ je mitigé parce que c'est
toujours c'est toujours c'est toujours
un peu délicat de de miser de miser
vraiment sur l'avenir mais il y a deux
arguments qui me font penser que c'est
qu'il est extrêmement prometteur et qui
pour il pourrait réussir jusqu'à la
Formule 1 c'est la longévité parce que
je me souviens très bien de ce de cette
de cette interview sur sur ce plateau
puisque j'intervenais quand on prend une
fois qu'on parlait de rugby après sur ce
plateau là donc j'intervenais
j'intervenais juste après donc j'avais
croisé ce petit bonhomme ce petit
bonhomme et son père et donc c'est c'est
une longévité grâce
et on a un petit peu discuté c'était
c'était touchant et là aussi prometteur
de voir à quel point il était il était
couvert il était protégé mais aussi
poussé motivé dans son dans son art
maintenant on est dans son sport
et puis le deuxième argument sur le sur
cette sur cette promesse c'est que c'est
en France et qu'en France en gros on a
on a vu sur les sur les sur les 20 30
dernières années en Formule 1 il y a
ceux qui venaient du milieu du milieu du
sport automobile dont Dieu dont le
karting comme Esteban Ocon récemment si
on reprend après les les ceux qui
tournent en ce moment au Formule 1 comme
Leclerc le Monégasque ou Pierre Gasly
c'est c'était dans cette dans cette déjà
dans cette mouvance et ils ont franchi
les étapes petit à petit de la formule
du karting jusqu'à jusqu'à la Formule 1
en passant par les en passant par les
catégories inférieures et puis il y a
aussi des des panisses et des alésies
qui ont qui ont qui ont eu leur place
dans les paquets de Formule 1 et qui
était pas forcément déjà pas forcément
du sérail alors oui donc c'est ça n'en
même pas un tout le karting mais il a il
a
Elias ce petit génie il a il a plus de
chance ou plus de chances d'y arriver
avec justement c'était cette expérience
réussie qui commence à durer
effectivement qui commence à durer et
puis et puis il a quand même à ce record
d'un titre de champion de France à 7 ans
alors il faut il faut il faut aussi
prendre avec des pincettes justement ce
talon brut bien le faire naturel mais je
crois qu'il est bien qu'il est sur les
bonnes pistes grâce à son entourage
grâce à ses entraîneurs et aux écuries
dans le dans lesquels il est dans
lesquels il performe donc oui moi j'ai
oui j'ai envie d'y croire et ça sera pas
forcément facile c'est pas du tout cuit
sa loi de là mais j'ai envie d'y croire
Philippe volak moi j'ai ouais comme tu
dis j'ai envie d'y croire aussi moi je
pense qu'il est bien entouré pas que
familialement en plus je pense que il y
a en plus aucun de la famille Ocon c'est
quand même pas n'importe qui je pense
que voilà on voit aussi qu'il a changé
des curry c'est quand même qu'il est
qu'il est voilà il est regardé on voit
ses performances ses performances je
pense que ouais et puis je trouve que je
trouve qu'il a sur les épaules il est il
va il va gagner en maturité par rapport
à aussi à 7 ans déjà qu'il était
champion déjà champion de France à 7 ans
mais voilà
je suis d'accord
maturité et il a la tête sur les épaules
il aurait pu avoir la tête qui tourne
avec effectivement des écuries qui sont
à son chevet etc et il est déjà dans une
stratégie de communication parce que je
me rappelle qu'en Mathilde Franco qui
présentait les sept émissions au jour là
lui demande quel est son écurie préférée
il a dit toutes les écuries et on sent
déjà qu'il est dans une stratégie de
communication de pas vexer personne et
que forcément quand on vient un milieu
pas forcément aussi qui ne se refuse
rien et il dit toutes les portes sont
ouvertes le désavantage on va dire le le
point négatif avec lequel il part c'est
qu'il vient pas d'une famille très aisée
donc il va devoir se construire et jouer
sa carte au talent attirer des
financeurs pour pouvoir des sponsors
pour pouvoir concourir l'année prochaine
en formule 4 et c'est une histoire un
peu similaire à celle d'automne
Ocon à la base il vient pas d'une
famille très riche et il a réussi quand
même à performer en Formule 1 c'est plus
difficile quand on n'a pas forcément les
moyens on va dire de millionnaire parce
qu'on a déjà vu des pilotes je pense à
je troll forcément qui arrive assez
facilement Formule 1 j'ai pas qu'il a
pas de talent mais parce que certains
sont porteurs aussi d'un marché aussi on
pense à ça par exemple avec le Mexique
aussi qui est tout à fait
sponsors assez facilement volant d'une
Red Bull donc oui forcément on amène
avec soit 16 sponsors on amène avec soit
son argent et peut-être que c'est le
point négatif avec le californ mais avec
le talon je pense qu'il va forcément
trouver aussi des gens qui vont pouvoir
le suivre dans cette aventure j'en
voulais rajouter quelque chose
le côté financier c'est ce que je ce
dont je parlais il est pas voilà il est
pas issu d'une famille riche donc ça va
être compliqué on le suivrait en tout
cas avec attention sur les prochaines
émissions et on espère ne pas attendre
encore quelques années pour pour le
revoir au plus haut niveau on espère le
voir dans les deux trois prochaines
années en formule 4 et pourquoi pas en
Formule 1 on croise les doigts pour lui
on garde les archives on regarde toutes
les archives on passe maintenant notre
page débat
[Musique]
on va maintenant parler d'un sujet d'une
thématique qui nous fait souvent réagir
sur ce plateau je veux bien sûr parler
du PSG le club de la capitale a
énormément de difficultés depuis le
début de l'année 2023 il pourrait
peut-être tout perdre dans cette fin de
saison les joueurs de Christophe Galtier
sont pour l'instant la première place
mais il compte seulement 6 points
d'avance sur lancée ils vont affronter
les 100 et hors prochainement ajouter à
cela une élimination en Coupe de France
contre l'OM et une élimination Ligue des
Champions 8e de finale contre le Bayern
Munich la question sur cette thématique
le club doit-il tout révolutionné pour
la saison prochaine oui ou non vous
votez oui pour vous Philippe voilà
non pour vous ah oui pour vous Grégory
canadet oui pour vous pierre et vous
êtes partagé Jean alors on va faire un
petit duel entre gens et Philippe
depuis longtemps on dit qu'il faut
révolutionner chaque chaque année chaque
saison ça se fait pas beaucoup je veux
dire ou alors il révolutionne mais bon
il met bout à bout d'autres
j'espère que que la saison prochaine ça
va être le ça va être le cas et c'est
une année encore en plus catastrophique
que les que les que les autres saisons
je veux dire là ils sont huit défaites
enfin l'année 2023 déjà parce que
le début de le début de saison jusqu'à
la Coupe du monde était très était très
bon je dis était très bon mais depuis le
mois de plus le mois de janvier c'est
ces catastrophique dans tous les sens
c'est catastrophique au niveau bon on a
parlé de l'entraîneur encore plus en ce
moment parce que voilà il y a encore une
autre affaire qui arrive on a parlé de
de comment du directeur sportif qui qui
vient en plus sur le terrain et qui qui
prend presque la place de Galtier en
venant en sur le terrain s'asseoir sur
le presque sur le banc à côté enfin
voilà il y a la non présence enfin quand
il vient du président et Kadhafi il y a
il y a énormément de choses il y a les
joueurs il y a des blessés comme moto
comme autant il y a des problèmes entre
les joueurs enfin bon c'est c'est chaque
année c'est là je crois que cette année
je crois qu'on touche le fond le fond ou
le je sais pas mais mais là il y a
quelque chose à faire il y a trop de
type de champion de France oui qui
peuvent encore mais ce serait le 11e
titre mais est-ce que est-ce qu'ils sont
vraiment ils se disent tiens on est
champion de France on se demande des
fois si les joueurs ils se disent ouais
en 60 France ou pas qu'est-ce que ça
fait voilà Jean
je suis mitigé pourquoi parce que tout
simplement je reviens pas ce que
Philippe a dit justement tous les
problèmes qu'il peut y avoir
actuellement
tout révolutionné alors qu'on n'est pas
dans une bonne phase ça peut ça peut ça
peut faire très très mal au club je
pense qu'il peut même ne pas s'en
relever donc je pense qu'on il faut
révolutionner un certain moment mais
pour moi il faudrait quand le club va
bien entre guillemets là il est limite
catastrophe Philippe l'a dit et on
touche le fond ou le bas comme vous
voulez c'est pas laquelle 16 vous mettez
mais donc c'est peut-être pas le bon
moment parce que encore une fois c'est
ça peut être ça peut être ça peut être
un électrochoc qui fait qu'ils ne se
relève pas je crois qu'il y a quand même
d'énormes problèmes tout le monde le
sait depuis on en parle tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps il y a on
dirait que rien n'est structuré dans ce
club pourtant c'est le club qui est mis
en avant qui est hyper professionnel et
quand j'écoute quand j'entends on dirait
que rien n'est structuré on voit on voit
des absurdités qu'on voit dans des clubs
amateurs ou il faut remettre sur pied le
le gars qui fume pas de travers non tu
as pas le droit de faire ça et là on
voit un club professionnel dit le plus
un des plus grands clubs de France sur
du monde pourquoi pas allons-y mais non
mais c'est ridicule c'est les gamineries
l'autre qui vient sur le bas ne touche
c'est pas sa place tu dégages autonome
quand tu fous là allez hop dégage il y a
pas de patron on dirait qu'il y a pas il
y a pas de patron dans ce club dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure les tensions en
interne les résultats qui suivent pas
sur sur le truc sauf que l'incertitude
liée au stade sauf que même sauf que
nous voilà bien sûr
ce que je dis c'est-à-dire que là le PSG
on devrait pas avoir c'est c'est petit
problème de de dysfonctionnement c'est
c'est c'est on perd du temps on perd de
l'énergie on perd on perd beaucoup de
choses sur des choses qui qui devrait
pas y avoir il y a 5 y a pas de patron
et on sent qu'il y a pas de structure
donc restructurer oui à mes tarifs les
gens à leur place et qui reste à leur
place qui reste à leur place qui fasse
leur boulot et pas les voir ce que fait
l'autre à côté mais de la tout
révolutionner pour moi attention c'est
pour ça que je suis mitigé je dis
attention pierre qui vous a convaincu
avec Jean sur le sur l'aspect sur
l'aspect risqué de la Révolution
l'argument que que Jeanneau a pris me va
très bien c'est sur le sur les rôles qui
ceux qui sont qui sont employés
et pas respecté et pas respecté au PSG
en sport les présidents brésiles les
entraîneurs entraînent les joueurs
jouent et là on a on a on a des on a des
passerelles qui se font quasiment depuis
le début on a on a une un rôle
prédominant de Nasser qui a priori veut
s'occuper du sportif moins au moins dans
le recrutement pour pouvoir enfiler les
stars comme les perles dans cette équipe
et puis on a on a des on a justement des
stars et ce carré d'as qui est qui est
fatigué qui est fatigué la gros le gros
point d'interrogation donc est-ce qu'on
va pouvoir garder celui qui nous tient
la baraque depuis trois saisons avec le
kicks est-ce qu'il va pas avoir à céder
aux sirènes d'un Real Madrid ou autre
club et si le PSG continue à faire des
erreurs de communication à ne pas le
mettre dans la boule comme il l'a fait
récemment cette semaine en le mettant en
avant lui plus que lui plus que toute
l'équipe et c'est là et c'est là où on
voit c'est là où on voit toute la
grandeur de Kylian Mbappe parce que
c'est la star de ce club là et c'est lui
qui c'est lui qui le maintient à ce
niveau là depuis au moins trois saisons
la Ligue des Champions en moins mais il
préfère le faire avec humilité et ça
c'est tout à son honneur donc voilà les
rôles et puis moi j'ajouterai un
argument qui me faisait un petit peu
être mitigé c'est l'aspect formation
c'est à dire que ça fait quand même
quelques saisons qu'on n'a pas vu les
petites pépites et il y en a qui sont
formés par le PSG et qui et qui qui ont
leur chance en en Ligue 1 et en Ligue
des Champions
à la place on préfère on préfère aligner
un verratti qui est qui est complètement
cramé et qui est ou un Neymar pareil on
en reparlera plus tard qui qui est aussi
passe plus de temps à à faire autre
chose que je joue au football voilà donc
c'est c'est oui il faut un électrochoc
au moins est-ce que c'est une révolution
et tout changer il y a des risques
Jeannot la rappeler
elle est quand même nécessaire et
Philippe Philippe la ok c'est de toute
façon ça c'est que c'est des réactions
de supporters de supporters déçus parce
que là là il n'y arrive plus c'est
effectivement comme le comme le FCV à
son niveau c'est c'est une équipe qui
toute porte bien évidemment qui est une
équipe qui arrive plus et pourtant le
PSG qui sont obligés souvent de partir
assez tôt même avant alors ils sont ils
ont leur premier contrat professionnel
ils ont pas encore tout à fait éclos
dans le groupe professionnel et ils s'en
vont il y a moi l'exemple qui me vient
en tête forcément c'est koman ce joueur
on a on lui avait pas forcément donné
toutes ses chances il était parti
ailleurs il a explosé ailleurs
aujourd'hui voilà mais il y a plein il y
a plein de gens du PSG qui partent
marquent souvent contre le PSG
d'ailleurs en Ligue des Champions
particulièrement
je pense qu'il y a eu deux dynamiques
dans un premier temps au tout début
quand on se souvient de l'arrivée des
Cathary je pense qu'il y avait des
bonnes décisions qui avaient été prises
même si après il s'est perdu dans ses
choix je trouve que Leonardo au tout
début de l'air qatari au PSG avait été
un bon directeur sportif il y avait eu
des très bon pourquoi notamment pour moi
la privée d'Ibrahimovic c'est un choix
fort mais c'est un choix qui a structuré
professionnel dans le club Ibrahimovic
au delà d'être le joueur qu'on
connaissait sur le terrain dans le
vestiaire c'était aussi un leader et qui
a construit un groupe assez victorieux
et quand on regarde les les progression
sur ses premières années il y a des
quarts de finale qui sont arrivés très
vite en Ligue des Champions même dès la
première année dès la première
participation du PSG car de finale
jusqu'à cette raie montada qui a un peu
tout changé les Qataris sont dit on va
tout révolutionner à l'époque on va
mettre des millions d'euros sur la table
pour attirer Mbappé pour attirer neymar
et j'ai l'impression que depuis cette
remontada ou bah voilà aux yeux de
l'Europe il y a eu une honte qui je
pense ne sera jamais lavé parce que
voilà perte de cette façon face au FC
Barcelone quand on a gagné 4-0 à l'aller
le 6-1 je pense que il sera jamais lavé
au moins dans la mémoire des supporters
et à coups de millions à coups de
milliards même on a plus d'un milliard
investi depuis l'arrivée des qatari on a
voulu réparer les failles des failles
peut-être au niveau de l'institution oui
le qui avait été très mal géré ce joueur
qui était quand même allé jusqu'à
insulter son entraîneur sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui a été très vite réintégré
on s'est rendu compte que l'institution
PSG derrière était n'était pas forte ok
on met des millions et on fait on attire
les meilleurs joueurs de la planète dans
l'effectif du PSG mais s'il y a pas une
institution pour les gérer s'il y a pas
aussi un entraîneur qui est là pour
gérer tous ces ego c'est très difficile
maintenant ils ont tenté moi je trouve
une mini révolution l'été dernier en
faisant appel à Louise Campos en faisant
appel à un entraîneur français comme
Christophe Galtier ils ont fait arriver
des joueurs comme moukili comme étiquité
et éthique et je vais y arriver et qui
ticket voilà mais il est très dur à dire
et qui devrait partir d'ailleurs le
mercato prochain mais ils ont ils ont
tenté une mini révolution cet été bah
voilà une révolution qui est capable
forcément forcément pris aujourd'hui il
y a même tout un tas d'incertitude moi
je je le disais tout à l'heure le stade
pour moi c'est une question centrale ne
plus jouer au Parc des Princes là on
compte totalement avec l'histoire du PSG
il y a voilà on perd une identité il y a
des vrais dossiers aussi à élucider donc
il y a beaucoup de choses sur la table
on va continuer justement à parler du
PSG de d'un joueur qui nous fait aussi
beaucoup parler ici sur ce plateau c'est
Neymar actuellement convalescence Neymar
s'occupe le joueur brésilien a perdu un
million d'euros en jouant au poker il y
a quelques jours il a filmé sa réaction
il apparaît triste dans un premier temps
mais il a ensuite éclaté de rire mais
rassurez-vous quand même il a gagné
35280 euros ce lundi soir sur le casino
Blaze dont il l'a il est là des sponsors
il avait misé sur plusieurs numéros à la
roulette et il a gagné alors la question
sur cette thématique bah tout simplement
votre avis votre avis sur non on valide
pas
aller voir
oui c'est clairement parti genre je sais
que vous êtes en panne mais ça c'est les
questions pour genre ça je le connais
c'est souvent les questions politiques
je viens de parler là voilà ça c'est
c'est un exemple type voilà de ce garçon
qui fait tout son jeu au football
et en plus c'est pour moi c'est déplacé
regardez il a l'air super concentré
un quart d'heure avec lui les investir
c'est déplacé par rapport aux tous les
phénomènes qu'on vit actuellement de
société balancer des des chiffres comme
ça
rigoler d'avoir perdu un million
avoir gagné 32000 euros faut quand même
relativiser si pour lui l'argent ne
représente rien ne vaut rien pour des
millions de personnes ça représente
quelque chose je trouve très déplacé ce
genre de de de comportement de publicité
pour un garçon qui est immature qui est
qui est à la limite après c'est sponsors
je le défends quand même mais bon
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on balance pas
des choses comme ça moi pour moi ce
garçon il est à l'image de Luc du club
actuel c'est à dire déstructuré voilà
pierre valeur au singulier et au pluriel
déficit des déficit de valeur
au pluriel chez ce chez ce joueur le
message qu'il envoie le timing n'est pas
bon sportivement il y est pas et donc il
a il attire la lumière peut-être sur un
pour un sponsor mais
pour lui sur des sur une mauvaise un
mauvais axe et la valeur la valeur qu'il
met en scène comme ça c'est ça nous
rappelle aussi le ça nous fait faire les
calculs de de ce qu'il a coûté au PSG et
de ce qu'il a rapporté en face là pour
le coup le compte n'y est pas mon cher
Kévin et donc
c'est assez navrant c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas à l'échelle de ce qu'on attend
d'un champion d'un porte drapeau alors
certes vendeur de maillot mais mais
d'abord drapeau de cette équipe mais
avant galactique avant de signer au PSG
il savait déjà que c'était un fan de
poker parce que c'est depuis 2014 la
Coupe du monde 2014 que c'est coéquipier
de l'équipe
nationale qui l'ont et il est même parti
en demi-finale de c’était là où vous
avez pris 7-0 il était parti avant la
fin
contre l'Allemagne et ouais quand même
presque pareil et il était parti avant
la fin il était parti jouer et jouer au
poker donc mais après tu vas pouvoir
dire
qui est est autant d'émotion ok football
c'est un peu normal qu'il soit tout à
fait tu le vois jouer qu'il est souvent
au tapis parce qu'il est tapis
Grégory pigment c'est bientôt la fin de
cette émission quand on commence à
parler plus des phrases que d'un joueur
en dehors du terrain que de ses
performances sur le terrain c'est qu'il
y a un vrai problème qui peut citer
aujourd'hui un dernier exploit de Neymar
sur le terrain enfin au premier match
contre Rennes voilà bah moi j'avais même
presque envie de dire la raie mandat le
match qui fait face au PSG avec le FC
Barcelone non mais il fait des bons
matchs avec le PSG mais pour moi son
match référence ça ça reste son match au
FC Barcelone face au PSG euh il a
d'ailleurs dit hein dans son
documentaire et donc depuis moi j'ai du
mal à trouver pourtant c'est un joueur
qui était pétri de talent à la base et
qui devait gagner à mon avis un ballon
d'or au moins dans sa dans sa carrière
et faire gagner son équipe c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission va terminer comme
d'habitude par une citation aujourd'hui
je vous propose une citation de l'ancien
footballeur
Eric Cantona la vie est toujours trop
cruel tout ce que nous pouvons faire
c'est d'essayer de passer le ballon et
laisser le soleil briller en espérant
qu'il brille pour tout le monde je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]